el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski volvió a pedir una mediación de
israel para poner fin a la guerra entre
rusia y ucrania dijo que jerusalén sería
un buen lugar para llevar a cabo las
negociaciones que según él ocurrirán
tarde o temprano siendo uno de los pocos
que mantiene buenas relaciones con ambas
partes el primer ministro israelí
naftalí bennett ha conversado en varias
ocasiones con gerentes que y el
mandatario ruso vladimir putin pero este
lunes admitió que si bien ha habido
avances aún existen brechas en temas
fundamentales para que la mediación
avance este nuevo llamado de seles que
ha aparecido bajar un poco el tono tras
el duro discurso del domingo frente a la
génesis del parlamento israelí en esa
intervención cuestionó la neutralidad de
israel en el conflicto dijo que no se
puede mediar entre el bien y el mal y
reprochó no haber recibido una
protección militar como es el sistema
cúpula de hierro o que israel no se haya
adherido a las sanciones internacionales
de la catarata de críticas en la que
peor cayó entre algunos diputados y
miembros del gobierno fue el paralelismo
que hizo entre la destrucción liderada
por rusia y el holocausto judío aunque
la política israelí no es ajena a la
instrumentalización del holocausto en
este caso fue bennett quien considero
que no puede compararse con nada más
allá de esta polémica israel sigue
defendiendo su postura en palabras del
gobierno responsable y sensible pero que
en realidad es un delicado equilibrio
entre su relación con rusia países del
que depende para coordinar ataques a
objetivos pro iraníes en siria y su
vínculo histórico con ucrania que cuenta
con una numerosa comunidad judía en la
que también se incluye incluye
excelencia mientras se mantiene su
asistencia humanitaria por ejemplo con
un hospital de campaña y la acogida
temporal de hasta el momento unos 15 mil
ucranianos israel espera que su riesgosa
postura mediadora se materialice